what's going on guys this is rob and i
was gonna do a breakdown for the new
trailer but something else caught my eye
as i was going through all the little
easter eggs and everything right some
that are bigger than others and one of
the things that i do want to make a
video on is i do want to talk about how
the necro sword will most likely lead
into the introduction of null because we
know that sony and marvel are both
working on a joint project that involves
null the symbiote god so this is going
to be pretty cool literally spider-man
no way home set the stage for this
actually it was the post-credits scene
on venom that set the stage for this and
essentially told us like know what's
coming but we'll talk about that in a
future video the thing about this is
that in the the trailer itself right 42
seconds and a minute and 48 seconds
these are the two points of the trailer
that matter for our discussion here so
at 42 seconds there is a point where you
see jane foster thor and in the
background you see the statue heads of
the living tribunal and the watcher now
at a minute and 48 seconds you get what
looks like the exact same shot but it's
wider and this time you get to see the
heads of mistress death the living
tribunal the watcher infinity and most
likely eternity again there's no
guarantee that's the case but infinity
and eternity are literally brother and
sister right where one goes the other
goes so they kind of go hand in hand but
the thing about this is that this is
kind of big because i think this is
omnipotent city now for those of you
guys who have read thor god of thunder
you specifically know exactly what i'm
talking about right the halls of the
all-knowing and all that kind of stuff
so one of the things to know is that in
marvel comics what you have is a place
called omnipotent city it's basically
this giant library where any god can go
and study the histories of any other
gods or anything like that now the
reason why this matters is because in
the god butcher storyline one of the
things that happened is that thor had
gone to omnipotent city and he had gone
through the library and found there was
this section of all these gods that had
basically gone missing they were simply
inactive or something like that and no
one knew what had happened to them they
were literally m.i.a and so it was kind
of like okay like it was a huge number
of people that was basically a tie into
what was going on with gore that in
effect all these gods that has simply
gone missing were basically killed by
gore or they had been taken as slaves
gore had actually used them in the
future to construct the god bomb but in
effect like thor was on the hunt to
figure out where all these gods had gone
unwittingly on the trail of gore the god
butcher which of course he figured out
that's what was going on when he
confronted gore and the two of them
fought and then gore beat the hell out
of him but the thing about this it was
one of the best moments in the comic
dude when gore beat the dude the first
time they fight if i remember correctly
gore beats the hell out of thor i mean
it's it's nuts man he dude he he beat
him like he owed him money it was crazy
[Laughter]
thor never had a chance and then and
then oh it gets even nuts like in the
future it's literally three thor's right
thor from the past before he could lift
mjolnir thor from the present when he
was able to lift the hammer and thor in
the future who's become the all father
they're all facing off against no i'm
sorry against gore and they still lose
it literally takes thor from the present
wielding two million years and the
all-black necro sword to defeat gore and
even then it still doesn't work
even then he doesn't necessarily destroy
him completely it's crazy right it's
just it's it's just it's nuts how
powerful that guy becomes just a
testament to how much the the all-black
necrosword just amplified his power it
was wild but the thing about this is
that omnipotence city is something that
would easily be introduced into thor 4
like quite literally it's a place where
like they could end up traveling to now
it also wouldn't surprise me if they do
a little bit of a change here that where
gore is just traveling around the cosmos
going from world to world and killing
gods that what he's actually done is
infiltrated omnipotent city and then
attacked it and then in turn basically
taken it over but the reason why this
matters regarding like death and the
living tribunal the watcher infinity all
those different guys is because we don't
know where they are right i mean like
the idea of the cosmic entities was
introduced way back in the first
guardians of the galaxy film if you guys
recall that it was introduced way back
then right like the artwork that was
added in for like the blu-ray and all
that kind of stuff it was one of those
things where it wasn't officially part
of the movie but james gunn and all them
were like cosmic entities exist in the
marvel cinematic universe you haven't
seen them yet but like they're there in
some form or fashion we don't know what
happened to them we don't know where
they are or anything but it would make
perfect sense that the cosmic entities
would be considered gods among gods
themselves and that in turn the cosmic
entities for whatever reason are out of
the picture we've seen that over the
course of the mcu so far right that
literally like in the loki tv series and
in doctor strange too there's been all
these references and things so like the
watcher and to the living tribunal and
so on and so forth i mean we literally
saw the watcher
in the what if series
we know he exists so it's one of those
things where like i wouldn't go as far
as to say that like these cosmic
entities have somehow been destroyed and
they're out of the picture and they're
missing it's simply that like yes they
exist and these halls within the uh
within omnipotent city reflect them
right like these halls basically say
like these beings exist and these are
statues that we make in honor of them
right or is a testament to them right
the gods among all gods now whether or
not that means the goal of gore is to
destroy all the cosmic entities and
everything in existence the universe the
whole nine yards i'm not entirely sure
but i wouldn't be surprised if that was
the case because one of the things that
surely you guys have noticed ever since
the events of spider-man no way home is
the stakes have been getting higher in
the marvel cinematic universe like the
stakes have been getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and higher and higher
like the first 10 years we're literally
just thanos wants to get the infinity
gauntlet and blink out half the life in
the universe and i mean let's be honest
with ourselves you know i mean it's not
the worst thing i mean it's it's a louis
ck skit right yes but maybe yes
yes it's awful that thanos wanted to
blink out half the life in the universe
but maybe
maybe
i'm just saying we all know that one guy
right where if thanos existed here in
the real world and thanos wanted to
blink out half of the life in the
universe
it wouldn't be so bad if that dude was
one of them you know what i mean like we
all know that one person but like those
are i mean looking at it for what it is
it's small time stuff right it's not the
most significant thing loki brought back
the multiverse dr strange screwed with
it and spider-man no way home and then
he explored it and doctor strange too
and wanda was jumping out jumping around
it right wreaking havoc across it and
doctor strange too like the stakes are
getting bigger so it wouldn't surprise
me if in this movie there's all kinds of
little references and easter eggs like
the the whole god pantheons sky fathers
and all that kind of stuff and in turn
it's one of those things where it's like
yeah man the cosmic entities are there
right because this is the time for them
to introduce the sky fathers right to
literally say okay thor so like you knew
odin as like your dad who was usually a
dick and he did some stuff i knew him as
a member of the sky father's council
right like myself and odin and vishnu
and probably almond raw if they want to
bring in moon knight right and just
bring in like the the any ad right the
pantheon of egyptian gods and just be
like we would all just hang out and talk
about stuff right we'd get our nails
done and share our feelings we're modern
men
you know that kind of a thing and so uh
that would be the time to do it but with
gore himself right his campaign in the
comics was wiping out gods across the
entirety of the universe it wouldn't
surprise me if he got a little too big
for his britches and started targeting
cosmic entities and even if they don't
necessarily exist and we don't see them
which i doubt we would see him attacking
a cosmic entity in this movie this would
be the time whereby they're like cosmic
entities are there man i just thought it
was i thought it was a huge thing right
because that is most likely omnipotent
city there is probably going to come a
point in that movie when odin's son or
jane foster or whoever ends up going
there and they're exploring where all
these gods have gone right we saw the
point in the first trailer when you had
korg and you had thor who saw the body
of like that giant gladiatorial god who
was there and so it's kind of like okay
like that can't be the first time they
noticed it that like gods in different
places are being killed and so in thor
wanting to understand this greater
pantheon of gods that he probably
doesn't really know much about in all
honesty because it's never really had a
reason to explore it he travels to
omnipotent city to learn and then along
the way we're given the introduction
that like the cosmic entities and living
tribunal those guys they're all real and
they're all exist they all exist and
they're they're all out there doing
whatever they're doing which apparently
is not caring about anything that
happens in the multiverse and then like
here are all the gods that have
basically been killed or have gone
missing right and that's kind of the the
sort of the thing that you used to go
forward right a kind of whodunit mystery
to a degree inside of this story but
nonetheless right i mean i'm curious
right i mean i'm really really curious
because i have a hard time believing i
mean this is the most on the nose that
we've seen from from the marvel
cinematic universe where they're like
cosmic entities y'all it's the most on
the nose thing right like the living
tribunal statues head appearing in loki
was kind of like okay cool nice little
easter egg and the point when like
doctor strange and america chavez are
falling through the multiverse and they
presumably pass through the realm of the
one above all that feels like more like
an easter egg or just a quick little
scene a moment in time like that's the
universe that exists out there but we
don't know anything about it this is
quite literally most likely omnipotent
city a city dedicated to the existence
and in the knowledge of all gods that
exist in the marvel cinematic universe
presumably in that universe and if the
the heads the statues of the living
tribunal and mistress death and infinity
and eternity and the watcher are all
there then that really has to mean
something
that's got to be big
it can't be a small thing so let me know
what you guys think right i want to hear
your most insane theories on what you
think this means right what what do you
think this stands for do you think it
stands for nothing do you think it means
everything do you think that like we're
leading to some great big huge
cataclysmic event where like we're gonna
end up seeing those cosmic entities
appear properly or do you think it's one
of those things where they're just
constantly doing these easter eggs that
lead towards nothing because i have a
hard time believing that's the case i
have a hard time believing that like
these cosmic entities are appearing in
different capacities and none of it
means anything so let me know what you
guys think thank you all for watching i
will catch you all later
peace